vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bien plus dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir 79 civils
tués par les djihadistes le nouveau
bilan du massacre de sites en ga au
nord-est du burkina faso un deuil
national de trois jours a été décrété
nous reviendrons sur ce drame dès le
début de ce journal
boris johnson va mettre à exécution sa
menace les premiers migrants partiront
ce mardi de l'ombre et seront envoyées à
plus de 6000 km au rwanda leur demande
d'asile sera prêté à kigali la procédure
continue ceci dit de susciter la
polémique
le prochain champion du monde du 100 m
sera t'il africain ferdinand omaya nyala
et kenyans et il suscite beaucoup
d'espoir il est devenu le nouveau
champion d'afrique rencontrent à la fin
de ce journal
le carnage a commencé samedi en fin de
journée mais le bilan vient d'être revu
à la hausse soixante dix neuf civils ont
été tués par des hommes armés des
expéditions punitives dans le village de
certains gars au nord-est du burkina
faso le pays a entamé ce mardi un deuil
national de trois jours à orly sud dont
croit-il
alors que le pays pleure les dizaines de
civils tués dans le village du nord des
survivants arriva d'orry la ville la
plus proche culture et de mentalité
du bouc la maison
une fête où vous pouvez la porter je
vais les
les violences de ces temps gars ont
commencé jeudi lorsque des hommes armés
ont attaqué les forces de sécurité onze
gendarmes sont tués selon les survivants
les forces qui protégeait le village se
sont alors retirés du secteur
mais à nice on vit ni prendre des
positions allaient circuler les villages
et qu'ils aient toutes les versions un
clip qui les avaient même souvent les
portes et va créer
les attaques des indices se sont
multipliés au burkina faso depuis sept
ans avec des terroristes affiliés au
groupe etat islamique où al qaïda des
milliers de personnes ont été tuées
c'est cette violence qui a mené au coup
militaire de janvier de nombreux
habitants se disent déçus par le nouveau
gouvernement
les survivants de 7 ans gars 2 e veulent
repartir chez eux pour reconstruire leur
village
ils seront moins d'une dizaine a décollé
de nombre ce mardi soir direction kigali
les premiers demandeurs d'asile quitter
le royaume uni et dont les demandes
seront examinées par les autorités
rwandaises une procédure qui va à
l'encontre des conventions de genève et
suscite la polémique outre-manche claire
bonnet champ
cet hôtel de kigali s'apprête à
accueillir le premier groupe de
demandeurs d'asile expulsés du royaume
uni en les envoyant au rwanda à 6000
kilomètres de là le gouvernement de
boris johnson entend ainsi dissuader les
traversée illégale de la manche c'est un
point essentiel de notre stratégie pour
briser le modèle économique de ces gens
épouvantable ces trafiquants qui font
commerce de la détresse et les gens
payent souvent de l'or
depuis le début de l'année plus de dix
mille migrants ont traversé illégalement
la manche pour atteindre les côtes
britanniques porté par boris johnson la
mesure inscrite dans le plan immigration
du gouvernement a été validé par la
justice mais provoque un tollé en
grande-bretagne
les chefs de l'église anglicane dénonce
une politique immorale le prince charles
a lui jugé le projet consternant tout
comme de nombreuses organisations de
défense des droits de la donc on est en
train non seulement de se défausser
d'une façon odieuse et tout à fait
inhumaine mais d'envoyer vers un pays
qui ne respecte pas les droits de
l'homme c'est une sorte de refoulement
ce qui est tout à fait interdite pour
des personnes qui risquent une
persécution en vertu de son accord avec
kigali londres doit financer dans un
premier temps le dispositif à hauteur de
140 millions d'euros le rwanda précise
qu'il proposera à ces migrants la
possibilité de s'installer si des
personnes demandent l'asile au rwanda et
que leur demande est rejetée dans le
cadre du processus que nous avons mis en
place ici
elles auront toujours la possibilité de
résider légalement au rwanda
le rwanda où le gouvernement est
régulièrement accusé par des ong de
réprimer la liberté d'expression et
toutes opinions politiques et un pays où
la majorité de ces migrants n'ont aucune
attache
allez on passe au reste de l'actualité
en bref et en images au moins sept
personnes ont été tuées dont quatre
décapités dans les récentes attaques des
élites dans le nord-est du mozambique
des violences qui touchent des zones
jusqu'ici été relativement épargnée
d'après les nations unies dix mille
personnes ont fui leurs foyers en une
semaine
le premier ministre éthiopien évoque
pour la première fois de possibles
négociations avec les rebelles du tigre
est habillé remède a parallèlement
démenti que des discussions secrètes
étaient en cours avec le front de
libération de coki tigre et un conflit
oppose les oppose au gouvernement
fédéral depuis novembre 2020 mais une
trêve a été signé en mars dernier est
pour l'instant respecté le président
algérien a limogé mardi son ministre des
finances
abderrahmane raouya a été remerciée
quatre mois seulement après sa
nomination la présidence n'a pas précisé
les raisons de cette éviction
au parent au cameroun où une affaire
défraie la chronique depuis plus d'un
mois 1000 habitants ont vu leurs maisons
détruites par les autorités dans le
cadre d'un complexe hôtelier privée des
victimes ont multiplié les
manifestations son succès le
gouvernement les a toujours pas relogés
mais le promoteur lui soutient avoir
indemniser toutes les victimes un
reportage de tony manga claudiane sono
luc art mengo et michel rondeau
vaste terrain vague
des amas de gravats et une tombes
profanées voilà ce qui reste de ce
quartier où vivent environ 1000
habitants en plein coeur de douala des
habitants réveillés en mai dernier par
des bulldozer comme le montre cette
vidéo amateur
une opération de démolition ordonnée par
les autorités qui ont loué ce site est
un investisseur privé pour la
construction d'un hôtel 5 étoiles des
familles parfois installés ici du plus
près de 50 ans comme celle d'étienne on
ne nous a pas de caser quelque part on
ne va pas le manger quand même pas avant
le café je ne veux pas où aller après
une carence est
ici
comme etienne des centaines d'habitants
du dicolo ben ali estime avoit été
illégalement chassés de leurs villages
bien que possédant des actes de
propriété et des titres fonciers c'était
le titre foncier de notre eau papale
portait son nom pour faire entendre leur
voix une dizaine de tonnes avec à leur
tête charles belle ont mis sur pied un
collectif qui se réunit chaque semaine à
quelques mètres du site objectif
réclamer ses terres ancestrales nous
n'avons plus de vie nous dormons par
terre nous ont traités comme des canards
sauvages
sont nous des citoyens camerounais nous
n'avons plus de place nous avons
empêchés pour être né dans cet endroit à
300 km de là nous retrouvons le
promoteur du futur complexe hôtelier
dans ces produits ont des oliviers
chinois coté avoir obtenu le site dans
les règles de l'art s'il est 63 familles
qui font l'objet des déguerpissements
45 familles ont approuvé la convention
qui a été signée entre la chefferie et
le promoteur
les riverains ont eu deux formes une
indemnisation puis d'affaires loin
d'être tranchée puisque le gouvernement
vient de mettre sur pied une commission
ad' hoc chargée du lever les zones
d'ombré qui entourent ce dossier sur
lequel planent des soupçons de
corruption dans un pays où 80% du litige
judiciaire concerne les conflits
fonciers
ce projet qui inquiète les pêcheurs
locaux et les défenseurs de
l'environnement au sénégal
les travaux de la première usine de
dessalement d'eau de mer ont été lancés
censé améliorer l'approvisionnement en
eau de la métropole les écologistes
redoutent son impact sur le littoral
dakarois déjà décimé par les
privatisations et d'innombrables
chantier laurent berthet chien
le long de la côte dakaroise la plage
des mamelles est l'une des rares de la
capitale encore être accessible au
public mais ce petit coin de paradis est
aujourd'hui menacée car à quelques
centaines de mètres doit s'installer une
usine de dessalement d'eau de mer un
immense chantier qui inquiète ce
restaurateur
est toujours été contre projet mais
comment on a été d'alerter l'opinion
publique tout les concernait jusque là
y'a rien qui fait donc nous on est
obligé de se conformer à la décision de
l'état notre seule inquiétude c est ce
que yvon
[Musique]
lusine dont la construction a été lancée
en grande pompe fin mai devrait
permettre de réguler les pénuries d'eau
qui affectent régulièrement la métropole
mais le projet suscite aussi son lot de
critiques notamment de la part des
défenseurs de l'environnement qui
s'inquiètent de son impact sur le
littoral
ces pêcheurs redoutent également que les
rejets de lusine n'affecte leurs
activités
face aux critiques le gouvernement
sénégalais assure avoir pris toutes les
dispositions pour la maîtrise des
impacts environnementaux et la
préservation de l'écosystème marin macky
sall s'est également engagé à compenser
les pertes commerciales liées à la
construction de l'usiné
il s'appelle ferdinand omania l'aï les
kenyans c'est le sprinteur le sprinter
le plus rapide en ce moment dans le
monde il est devenu le nouveau champion
d'afrique au 100 m à l'issue des 22e
championnat d'afrique d'athlétisme qui
ont pris fin ce dimanche à maurice o
mania a été la révélation de ce
rendez-vous le jeune sprinter kenyan
prépare désormais les mondiaux
d'athlétisme avec pour ambition de
surprendre les américains chez eux
france24 l'a suivi à maurice reportage
dame de la hernie
alors qu'il détient la meilleure
performance mondiale de la saison au 100
m 9 secondes 77 réalisé le 18 septembre
dernier à nairobi c'est sur cette piste
à côte d'or que ferdinand home à nyala
est venu chercher son premier titre
celui de champion d'afrique prochain
défi les mondiaux d'athlétisme en oregon
aux états unis je suis en forme je suis
très en forme oui avant demain nous
reste encore un mois avant les
championnats du monde je peux vous dire
que nous allons battre les américains
chez eux
cet ancien rugbyman passé à l'athlétisme
a mis cinq ans pour développer sa masse
musculaire des sprinteurs fier d'être un
pur produit de l'athlétisme kenyan il
s'estime prêt à 26 ans à se faire
respecter parmi les grands noms du
sprint mondial son chrono de 9 77 fait
de lui le huitième meilleur performeur
de tous les temps et le seul africain se
hisser dans le top ten prémices croit-il
d'une nouvelle ère
le sprint a été dominée par les
américains et les jamaïcains ils doivent
commencer à oublier cela parce que les
africains arrivent je suis en ce moment
le leader mondial si je vais en oregon
c'est bien pour décrocher une médaille
je veux que le kenya et l'afrique soit
fier sur la piste de côte-d'or ferdinand
home à nyala et deux sud africains ont
couru sous les dix secondes
sous l'oeil du président de wella
reflète ex qui observe que l'esprit est
africain a acquis une nouvelle maturité
j'assiste à des performances de classe
mondiale sans métro trois athlètes ont
couru en moins de dix secondes exprit
africain arrive vraiment à maturité
concurrents sont très compétitifs dans
quelques semaines en oregon
de nouveaux sommets pour ferdinand oman
ya là les sprinteurs kényan est revenu
sur scène après une interdiction de 14
ans en 2017 pour cause de deux pages
qu'il a toujours nié il porte désormais
l'espoir de tout un continent à côte
d'or il faisait le bonheur de nombreux
fans
sur cette image que nous refermons ce
journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis et en particulier ceux
de nairobi à conakry en passant par
addis abeba
restez avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur son vainqueur
[Musique]